hey what's going on is Bill per and it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before a Friday Monday morning podcast
and I'm just checking in on you oh oh
how's it going in your little part of
the world huh
is it going all right oh [ __ ] I'm
still limpid from the [ __ ] new
[ __ ] I got torn on the last podcast
Jesus Christ did I ever claim to be a
smart guy that [ __ ] [ __ ] giving me
[ __ ] about the otamatone equinox
I've been looking that [ __ ] up for like
three days I'm like what exactly was he
talking about you know I [ __ ] is there
anything worse than when somebody
delivers new information in the tone
that that person did [ __ ] coming at
me like you discovered it you just read
about it what the [ __ ] you know I don't
anyway I still don't get I still don't
get why I go on the internet since the
summer's over to September 23rd he's
sitting there saying that's some
medieval [ __ ] I don't get it and if he's
so [ __ ] right that summer started
June 1st and ends August 31st I hope he
was out there flapping his [ __ ] wings
June 1st screaming in the Netherlands
wherever the hell he's from going you
guys
anyway it's Thursday August 15th Oh
start spreading the news I don't want to
be a part of it anymore this summer I
wanna fly back to a city where my stuff
is and say why did I buy all of this
[ __ ] what's going I'm going back to LA
today I'm going back to Cali take it
went we're in it hey freckles I don't
think so
well [ __ ] you my flight was canceled but
I'm still going at some point I don't
get [ __ ] I got taken fuss
[ __ ] duane allman did it he play slide
guitar better than I do I'll take a
[ __ ] bus and him I'll take a [ __ ]
train I will change in Chicago I won't
even get a sleeper car ticket I will
sleep sitting up for [ __ ] four days
going through some of the methi Esparta
this [ __ ] country and I'm not I don't
have a speech impediment
that's Methodist yeah going back to
California today with an aching in my
horror cannot wait to get back to my
[ __ ] I'm gonna get back to my stuff my
stuff and I'm going back and didn't
booze the whole summer my cigar smoking
is off the [ __ ] rails to the point I
have to shut it down you know I remember
my mother told me something about a
thousand times when I was a kid I don't
know how to do that you know I think
what I have to do is a bunch of bad
things a little bit you know a little
bit of meth in my life a little bit of
cocaine I don't [ __ ] with any of that
[ __ ] but you know what I mean I just
don't know how to do it so I'm not gonna
smoke a cigar
until I that that weekend when I'm going
to the [ __ ] Clem's in Florida State
but it's cool cuz I'm going back to my
house and I don't have any cigars in the
house so that's the thing no just take
me with just like four days then I won't
think about it anymore
and then at that point I won't be
drinking I won't be smoking cigars I'm
barely watching porn you know one of
those those [ __ ] TV shows you binge
watch you devour the first three seasons
and then they just start to lose you in
the fourth season it just fades away
that's what porn is like for me right
now and if I can just get that out of my
life start going to church on Sunday you
guys can start calling me old Billy
Flanders there that would be amazing an
amazing trajectory to this podcast where
I was an angry [ __ ] conspiracy theory
lunatic when I started you know
to go into a bald Jesus freak who
[ __ ] lectures you on why you're not
living a life the way you should
what whoa hey Nene looking good oh you
know I would never do that to a woman I
don't know but I reserve the right to
cat call my own wife hey sweetie what
are you doing later come on don't be
like that help me smile put a [ __ ]
smile on your faraday's hey what did you
come over here me I'll be adjust my tool
belt that Nia will be on here later
reading one of the funnier it's not an
email what would you call it a [ __ ]
post it was a review of some white lady
that went to a plantation and it was not
what she expected it to be the results
the results may shock you here's
something I did because I always watch
that the MotoGP races you know they come
on in like a ridiculous time in the
morning and when they were on TV I could
record them and watching the same day
but I have to wait today repost them if
I don't watch them live on their website
so I'm still waiting to see the video
soz win in the last race wherever the
hell it was so I went there and I was
like you know what I'm gonna look at
some of these other videos and they have
all these [ __ ] races you know from
back in the day you go all the way back
to like the early 90s if not the late
80s and I have to tell you man I get it
now when people fans of racing say you
missed it I just went back to 2002
because I wanted to see a young
Valentino Rossi when he was still riding
with Honda just to hear how they were
talking about him if they already knew
he was going to be one of the Great's
you know and it seemed like his careers
right where Marc Marquez career is right
now and but just like the level of
danger and even then they still had to
some sort of look like a [ __ ] airbag
they still have a little
thing on the pond they're back with
their their racing suit they're they're
racing leathers so I don't know how far
back the airbag technology goes but this
[ __ ] guy wiped out high-sided on his
bike and they came out they took him off
on a stretcher I was just like wow I
know my three years of watching the [ __ ]
I've never seen anybody go off on a
[ __ ] stretcher which is a good thing
but just when I watch old Formula One
races which is the best thing of going
to the f1 site and the MotoGP site is to
start watching some of the old races and
I wish you know if you could go on to
like the NF nfl.com and just watch a
game like I always wanted to watch that
game when Walter Payton ran for 275
yards against the Minnesota Vikings in
the late 70s and he set the record I
always wanted to see that game I've
never even seen NFL film highlights on
it I don't know it's a great way for a
fan who's new to the sport be they young
or an old fart like me it's a great way
to learn your history and be able to put
what you're seeing into some sort of
perspective so I watched this race then
what was really incredible was back then
that on the same in the same race they
had four stroke and two stroke engines
and for those people who are
mechanically inclined like myself that
just means two strokes means it's just
every two strokes it fires so as the
piston comes up the [ __ ] when he called
the spark plug fires boom drives it down
piston comes up at fighters just let's
just bang bang bang bang bang and we're
a four-stroke it's every fourth stroke
so it fires down up down fired down up
down fire the same thing so I guess the
the four strokes ran smoother and were
easier to handle and the two strokes
it was weird they had like more power so
they were lighter because there's a pass
on the race that I watched this [ __ ]
guy about 11 minutes into the race it
was look like a pass you'd seen a
motorcycle and a movie about motorcycle
Racing there was two turns and he just
[ __ ] opened the throttle and went
around but went around the outside of
one guy and on the inside of Valentino
Rossi and then Rossi just sort of you
know played with them for like the last
like ten laps and every time they got on
the straightaway he would kind of come
up on him just sort of almost like a
boxer measuring him you know feeling him
out or whatever and then he finally
passed him with like four laps to go and
then just took off but I couldn't figure
out how they was saying a four-stroke
had more had more power and I think it
was just the size of the engine cuz
everything I read said the two-stroke
had more power but was hard at a handle
or whatever but it was lighter and I
guess cuz its firing more it gave you
more power I don't know I don't quite
understand it but I found that element
being in the race something that's isn't
there anymore
and for all you mechanics out there
rolling your eyes go [ __ ] yourself okay
I listen to your jokes after my shows
okay you can deal with me talking about
it was really it was really [ __ ]
interesting so if anybody out there
knows more about that and can explain it
to me a little bit nicer than that
[ __ ] [ __ ] who tried to explain
the summer solstice to make in the
winter solstice and all that means is
with at the point when the Sun is the
highest or the lowest in the sky [ __ ]
guy yelling at me like like he figured
it out like the church wanted to burn
him so anyway my flight got delayed so
you probably won in a well built you're
in the greatest city in America and
cording according to New Yorkers where
you gonna go I'm actually I'm gonna go
to the met believe it or not and no I'm
not gonna go there you know to look at
some art you know by [ __ ] Gruyere
whatever the [ __ ] guys names are I
know that's a cheese that always sounded
like one of those [ __ ] artists like
back in the day when I was still in the
dating world and a woman say let's go to
the Met there's a Gruyere exhibit
I just ain't no I wish I could go back
then just so I wouldn't waste all that
time just be like I don't want to go
because I like the intellect for this to
be interesting to me all of it looks the
same it's just framed [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] about any of it I don't
understand why it's worth millions and
millions and millions and millions of
dollars
I think the Mona Lisa it's is [ __ ] it
you know this is average as the woman
that they've got the dude painted I mean
I would you hit on Mona Lisa I wouldn't
I mean he might as well a painted me
into that [ __ ] picture
oh there's a Photoshop for you I am
going there because Dean Del Ray let me
know they have some of the most famous
rock instruments you know and ever yes
at the Metropolitan Museum of Art Nia
come here speak into the mic if you're
gonna come over here go see the exhibit
camp notes on fashion which was the
theme of this year's Met Gala and I they
had a NASA like a space exhibit there's
do you know why they do that is because
the art of files can't sustain that
thing art of files so then what they
have to do is they got to bring the
mouth-breathers it
we've got Eddie Van Halen's axe from
[ __ ] mean Street I'm positive it's at
the met Dean Del Rey told me about it
it's not at another museum it's at the
Metropolitan they had they had [ __ ]
that Ralph Lauren's car collection at
one time oh they like our cars art what
they're really saying is all right we
need money here people come on this is a
74 Toyota Corolla with all the options
also no one cares if you would [ __ ] the
Mona Lisa or not okay nobody cares about
what [ __ ] turns you on in terms
the art world you know what you're
talking about would you hit on the Mona
Lisa do [ __ ] average you are like
this such a basic [ __ ] sometimes nobody
cares whether you would bang the Mona
Lisa
you're so yeah you're missing the point
in it but would they find it but would
they find it funny Wow was it that hard
was it that you just sounded like the
head of a corporation who got caught
dumping [ __ ] in the water supply do you
think it was good to put that in the
water yes
so they got a mouth breathing exhibit at
the meth and I'm going oh my god that's
that guitar from Lynyrd Skynyrd Whitney
Engler dude that's the one they got the
sweet home alabama' guitar they got the
flute from [ __ ] what's that band a
Led Zeppelin stairway to heaven I never
liked that call that stairway to my ass
starts off slow about time the guitars
come in I'm always asleep that's why I
like Skynyrd I always thought Skynyrd
was better than Zeppelin this is what
these conversations are gonna happen in
the Metropolitan University Metropolitan
of the [ __ ] is it Museum museum
everybody yeah but that's what these
museums have to do every once a while to
get mouth-breathers like me to come in
there and spend some money
our four-by-fours art went beep any
owning in it I will tell you this I did
go to one Museum the guy who did the
Reservoir Dogs to his ear that guy
Marvin Nash whatever his [ __ ] real
name is I went to his thing and he
paints with the straight lines I like
that that guy I liked fellow ginger had
a temper hey Mia you think I got a bad
temper I never cut my ear off and sent
it to you do you [ __ ] relax
Oh Billy Flanders Billy no vice beware
the man with no vice why do they say
that beware of the man with no vice
because what does that mean like he has
one you just don't know what it is and
someday the shoes gonna drop hey maybe
that atomic Equinox guy can [ __ ]
explain it to me hey [ __ ] all that
other guy who called me a boot licker
cuz I said that students shouldn't go
down Main Street and throw bricks
through mom-and-pop stores bootlicker
what are you doing rebel huh would you
tie a bandana around your [ __ ] head
sing a little Bruce Springsteen and all
of a sudden the FBI needs to open a file
on you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright what the hell was I just looking
up there beware of the man with no vice
what about the woman with no vice beware
the woman with no shoes without a shoe
fetish alright if a man has no vices
he's in great dangers of making vices
out of his virtues and there's a
spectacle no no nurse one vice in your
bosom what [ __ ] website is this
Thorton Wilder crushing it if a man has
no vices he's in great danger of making
vices out of his virtues like what going
to church and then [ __ ] spewing about
that and there's a spectacle people were
so much smarter back in the day huh at
least at least they won't eloquent the
way they talked hey Bill don't drag us
all down to your dumb level all right
fair enough
all right we've all seen them we've all
seen them men who were monsters of
philanthropy and women who were dragons
of purity no no nurse no no nurse one
vice in your bosom
I thought he was talking about some
nurses titties so dumb I am no no nurse
one vise in your bosom give it the
attention it deserves oh he says nurse
and let your virtue spring up modestly
around it Thornton Wilder you guys ever
hear him what does this guy's ever done
that's not the guy I wrote about the
pond is it who's that guy with the
[ __ ] pond everybody talks about
Thornton Wilder the son of a [ __ ] was
alive when I was alive 1897 to 1975 was
an American playwright and novelist he
won three Pulitzer Prizes for the novel
the bridge of San Liu Irae in the plays
our town in the skin of our teeth in the
US you know what I'm gonna read this guy
I'm gonna get one his books I'm gonna
look at it I'm reading the devil and
Sonny Liston right now someone on the
movie gave it to me one of the sound
guys I never even got his name and he
bought me a great book for my daughter -
I'm gonna read that and then I'm gonna
read Silent Spring and then I'm gonna
read I'm gonna read some Thorton Wilder
all right while I smoke a cigar now I do
have to lay off the cigars I got I got
to lay off them okay get a little too
[ __ ] shut it down what is Thorton
Wilder have to say about shutting it
down I'm gonna look up booze shutting it
down taking breaks here's what happens
to your body when you take a break from
alcohol if you drink occasionally or
more than occasionally rolling your eyes
you've probably considered taking a
break from alcohol at least once maybe
your doctor suggested it Jesus Christ is
that your letter abstaining for a health
reason or maybe you just realized that
your weekly happy hours were draining
your bank account people who take time
out from booze usually swear that it
makes them look and feel better should
you do it you know some things could
just really be [ __ ] answered in a
paragraph but for some reason people
want to write a whole [ __ ]
article on it so should you do it now
right there it should become yes you
should or no it really doesn't make a
difference but instead they launch off
into while drinking alcohol in moderate
amounts defined by the Dietary
Guidelines for Americans as having up to
one drink a day for women and up to two
day two drinks a day for men Jesus
Christ that's [ __ ] awesome hey Nia do
you know you drinking moderately you can
have one drink a day and I can have two
I'm that much bigger than you Nia I got
a good four inches on you that doesn't
make any sense
I would have to be twice your size
wouldn't I if you're five feet tall I'd
have to be 10 feet tall Harbor noted
Rick all right it's generally thought of
to be okay for your health having more
than that on a regular basis isn't and
it's easy to go above the moderate
levels yeah we know alcohol certainly
presents that quandary whether you feel
like you're at a heavier side you might
end up taking in a few calories your
immune system will improve it could
boost oh I just got to read the
headlines it'll boost can boost your
metabolism your level will be able to
function more effectively you'll sleep
better just a warning
you might overdo it when you start again
I've lived that and in the end they got
some woman doing yoga see how they do
that this is like somebody trying to
improve their life hey Nia when are you
gonna get in here and read the white
lady I'm gonna read some advertising
here all right all right Indo Chino talk
about people who look great in a suit
I'll tell you right now Brad Pitt and
[ __ ] the guy from the Titanic when
they came out and they had their suits
on to promote that Quentin Tarantino
movie I was just like yeah honey yeah
Leonardo DiCaprio endowed Chino is the
world's most exciting made-to-measure
menswear company they make suits and
shirts to your exact measurement
for an unparallel fit and comfort you
know it's great too when you get a
tailor-made suit you got to maintain
your weight all right no bull no you
can't get the Bill Clinton cut you know
when they make a big seat of the pants
and thighs this big [ __ ] of a body huh
he puts on weight like a woman in the
1800s you know that [ __ ] guy should
have painted his thighs and ass and put
it right next to the Mona Lisa looking
to get married they have tons of options
for those looking to outfit their
wedding party guys love the wide
selection of high quality fabrics and
colors to choose from not to mention the
option to personalize the details
including your lapel lining pockets
buttons and writing your own monogram
you got to bring that back young guys
young fellas out there that was the [ __ ]
back in the day it skipped my generation
you need to bring it back having your
initials on your cufflinks Nia you like
that right when a man has his initials
on it on the unleash shirt sleeve she
just said sure could can you sell it Nia
yeah there you go come on with a pocket
square and old-school gentlemen yeah
takes you out throws you around the
dance floor a couple times his dice says
right goes downtown make sure he takes
care of his business before he opens up
shop come on Nia all right guys love the
whites all right here's how it works
visit a stylist at their showroom
there's over 40 showrooms in North
America 40 states down tend to go I
always forget if this 52 I was think
cards and have them take over your have
them take your measurements personally
or measure at home yourself and shop
online at indochina choose your fabric
inside and out choose your design
customizations submit your measurements
for your choices relax while your suit
gets professionally taken and mailed to
you in a couple of weeks how do they fit
it in an envelope this week my listeners
can get any premium indochina suit for
just 300 $69 and Indo Chino comm when
entering BRR
checkout plus shipping is that's Indo
Chino IND Oh ch Ino calm promo code
Barbie you are R for any premium suit
for just three hundred $69 and free
shipping
it's an incredible deal for a for a
premium made-to-measure suit
once you go custom you don't go back all
right oh look who's here everybody
Dollar Shave Club me I got two more
reads get that thing ready Dollar Shave
Club - Dollar Shave Club has spent you
developing crafting refining all their
products the quality is second to none
they have everything you need to look
and feel and smell your best they have
basically everything you need for an
amazing shave the executive dr. cavies
ez shave prep scrubs and post shave do
and as amazing as their shave stuff is
Dollar Shave Club is way more than just
raises Dollar Shave Club has you covered
from head to toe they have everything
you need to shower shave style your hair
brush your teeth and yes even wipe your
ass and Dollar Shave Club can keep you
automatically stocked up on the products
you use I actually I could speaking of
wiping your ass you got to get the one
wipe Charlies they gave me some
complimentary ones I was tremendously
impressed you know clean as a whistle or
the wintergreen aftertaste my ass was
tingling Nia I always wanted what it'd
feel like to put a breath saver up my
ass and now I know thanks to one wipe
Charlies I you want you get what you
want wherever you need it
hey let's keep it clean here huh whether
that's once a month or a few times a
year as a Dollar Shave Club member
you'll never have to waste time at the
store wondering if what you're getting
is any good you know what you're getting
is the highest quality right now you can
put the quality of Dollar Shave Club
products to the test their ultimate
shave status set as basically everything
you need for an amazing shave the
executive shave
shave butter prep scrub and shave shave
do that's gonna gross the best part is
you can try it for just five bucks
after that the restock box ships regular
sized products at regular prices get
your ultimate status set for just those
and dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / birth that's
brought me the people downstairs telling
us to be quiet oh here's a movie I'm
gonna go see the good boys all right
what if the guys who made some of the
most outrageous r-rated comedies like
Superbad and sausage party decided to
make an r-rated comedy starring
twelve-year-old boys well they did and
it's the hilarious I would have said
pre-adolescents twelve-year-old
pre-adolescent you still gotta say boys
just saying twelve-year-old boys now
with that Epstein Story out that's just
weird well they did oh that's right now
he was into he was into girls well they
did and it's the hilarious new movie
called good boys
it follows three innocent sixth graders
as they skip school one day to do
whatever it takes to learn how to kiss
before their first middle-school party
the thing is they get themselves into a
ton of inappropriate and r-rated
situations along the way Nia get back
here early audiences and critics have
been raving about good boys saying that
you'll laugh for 90 minutes straight
they're calling it delightfully
inappropriate wildly raunchy and
undeniably sweet that's all you got to
do to get away with it you got to put
that don't forget to go see good boys in
theatres August 16th that would be
tomorrow all right help these guys have
a nice big weekend so Hollywood let some
hang around for another one it's how it
works all right Nia was of course right
here right where I needed her and then
the second I needed her she just went
away
come on the timing was perfect you're
ruining it my new favorite author
Thorton Niven Wilder what's the matter
what what's going on well she could have
texted you too
all right read it please wait you are
dropping the ball today Nia you see you
should see me everybody the lovely Nia
is even lovelier than ever
crushing it at the gym looking hotter
than ever
Wow still won't make eye contact with me
no all right
yeah yeah I mean you had at least 17
minutes I know I know I know
all right you keep it going all right
I'm gonna tell you right now the top
five reasons why Nia is lucky that she
married me one my looks too
no hair in the shower drain three Jesus
this is a tough one top two three
reasons I'll stop at three Wanya give me
a third reason what's that I'm looking
up the thing screeching halt everybody
see this is right here you know why they
make documentaries about whether women
are funny or not okay
nothing I thought that would get you
going oh I didn't tell this story so I
was out smoking a cigar there's a little
park outside the the 72nd Street stop on
the Upper West Side and I was sitting
there with a couple friends of mine and
all of a sudden this gay dude comes
walking by dress like [ __ ] Eleanor
Roosevelt whoever Herbert Hoover married
he looked like a first lady from the
1930s is what I'm saying with the
[ __ ] hat the little hat with the
[ __ ] veil over his eyes so we were
sitting there smoking cigars right and
he just comes [ __ ] and he had like a
wheelie sag like luggage
and we're sitting there and he just
comes storming through the middle of us
and he goes hey genius your dildos on
fire just kept walking and my first
thought was like wow I really missed
crazy people in New York and I'm such a
dummy
considering I'm a comedian I didn't get
that he was making fun of my cigar like
saying that I had that big dildo in my
mouth and I don't know I just wish I
knew in the moment I would have been oh
I love a woman with attitude I would
have said something oh you look
beautiful sweetheart or something like
but that's one of those things what this
is why Nia I still make fun of gay
people in my act because they're like
straight people well most of them are
[ __ ] that guys like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was smoking outside I'm in the
park is a [ __ ] homeless guy like two
feet away from me you know I'm paying
the price for my habit not enough for
this [ __ ] eight-year-old stewardess
walking by right all of a sudden hey
genius your dildos on fire
meow ladies meow all right so this is a
review of a plantation I don't know what
plantation but it went viral because
someone post about it on Twitter but the
review says it's just a real plantation
it's not wanted like Epcot Center is it
this is a real planting what do you mean
Epcot Center they had the plantation
exhibit to get the southerners to still
go to because Epcot's getting a little
old okay anyway they gave this
plantation two stars my husband and I
were extremely disappointed in this tour
we didn't come to hear a lecture on how
white people treated slaves we came to
get a history of southern plantation and
get a tour of the house and grounds the
tour guide was so radical about slave
treatment we thought we were being
lectured and bashed about the slavery my
ancestors was from Sicily never owned
slaves and my husbands were German and
none of his ever owned slaves I am by
far not a racist or against all
Americans having equal rights but this
was my vacation and now we were crossing
all plantation towards off our lives it
was just not what we expected I'll go
back to Louisiana and see some real
plantations that are much more enjoyable
to tour white-girl inflexion by me I
love that I took a tour of a plantation
this wasn't what I expected I went to a
switch and it just was not what I
expected
I like the minimalist vibe there I
thought it was gonna be about the
architecture I didn't think it was good
I was never a Nazi I never killed any
Jews that is like one of the funniest
[ __ ] like it I almost don't believe
that it's that is true that somebody
like we went to take a tour of a plant
like what other plantations are you
gonna go - it's a plantation lady like
that's that's what happened I was joking
when she read this it's like I took a
tour of NASA and it was just not what I
expected
okay I came there to look at some
Rockets not to hear about people burning
up on re-entry for the Advancement of
humanity okay I just felt like I was
getting a lecture like they're heroes
and I was somehow not brave I'm gonna go
to a fun rocket ship place yeah yeah I
don't know what this person expected
like they were you know they're telling
you about what happened on plantations
Mia for $1,000 would you have lunch with
her and she would just discuss her
philosophies on on politics and race
relations for $1,000 yeah I mean you
can't say anything
you have to nod like hmm like what she's
saying is amazing for $1,000 no no Mia
for $1,250 you get to pick the
restaurant my dignity is not for sale
five grand my integrity is not for sale
6,600 it's like an oven everybody has
their price the 10 grand untaxed and
peck on the cheek from Oprah Winfrey
saying you keep it up girl would you do
it
no no $11,700 a pair of Jimmy Choos
Oprah Winfrey Peck no taxes and an
all-expenses-paid trip to the French
Riviera Monaco for ten days no just
listen to this dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] she's
not gonna get smarter you just have to
listen to her for an hour and like not
an agreement whoa now like you're
watching a fireworks show that's all you
have to do 12345 dollars and
eighty-eight cents a trip to Calgary
Alberta to watch a home and home game
against the flames of the Edmonton
Oilers you get to go to Edmonton for
Game two and see the Northern Lights
then all you have to do is not express
an opinion you know Nia I'm calling
[ __ ] first of all I don't need your
approval to call [ __ ] okay this
conversation was not what I expected all
right well that's 36 minutes right there
just for us checking in on you Nia I got
to tell you you crushed it you did the
near impossible you went to New York
City and somehow you know on you know
it's not like we live here right so your
vacation there's all this great [ __ ]
peaks are out here oh man I had some
good pizza one big swing and a Miss we
will not mention
how big is swinging him is bigger than
that woman's swinging a Miss on the
plantation tour was just the food
equivalent no but it was for fourteen
thousand final offer that was
disappointing but that's okay it's okay
I went to that place good for them I
went to scars I love that place that
place that had the tang that had the zip
everyone's talking about - Farah that's
like as that's the spot it's de Farah I
thought I thought Ellen B was a little
bit better but they're both [ __ ]
incredible they're both you know what
they're equally amazing
they'll death sacrilegious that's like
what do you like better
you know Catholics or Protestants I mean
we're all this [ __ ] all right listen
to all you people from other religions
okay you're just gonna have to take that
one all right and I'm sure this podcast
was not what you expected all right we a
little bit of music here and then we're
gonna play a greatest sense from a
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcasts from Thursday
earlier this year and six years ago I
don't know how
but that's it have a great weekend you
can't sit I'll talk to you on Monday
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday
August 15 2011 big news big news again
this week
in case you didn't listen last week when
I announced it on Opie and Anthony this
was the big goddamn secret for those of
you out there who don't follow me on
Twitter or Facebook or anything like
that my big announcement was believe it
or not on November 11th 2011 I am gonna
be performing at Carnegie Hall
I'm going to be doing stand-up comedy in
Carnegie Hall New York City the real one
not that [ __ ] one out there in
Pittsburgh you don't I mean like like
when you say I go to the University of
North Carolina Wilkesboro I'm in one of
the satellite campuses no I'm on the
main one [ __ ] all right one were all
the fancy people with their horns and
their jazz musicians ship and their
speeches I'm going to be I'm gonna be
there thanks to Andrew Carnegie for
filling guilty at the end of his life
after you'd put his foot on the throat
of poor people he decided well let's
give him a building
to go down and enjoy musicand and you
know what I'm gonna name that building
after me I am gonna be performin I don't
be performing there and I know I'm
joking around about it but I am
absolutely blown away I can't believe it
and yeah I don't know it's been a long
cook me 20 years to get there just a
little under 20 years okay for you you
fantasy football stat douchebags out
there it was 19 years it'll be 19 years
what's what's 12 minute and 8 months and
in 9 days it took me to get there to go
from [ __ ] doing stand-up in the
basement of spaghetti Freddy's right
eating my goddamn balls one at a time
nice and slow downstairs where they got
all the extra pasta to get in a Carnegie
Hall so there you go youngsters young
comedians out there beat that beat 19
years eight months and [ __ ] whatever
how many date nine days nine days
alright if you can beat that you're a
better comic than me unless you have a
catchphrase then you can go [ __ ]
yourself because you cheated you didn't
cheat alright but you gave them what
they wanted didn't ya
ooh they liked when I said that what if
I say it again and the morons in the
crowd if you [ __ ] do that if you just
stand on there and you throw the raw
meat at those goddamn morons and let
them eat it up just the exact [ __ ]
way they want and know you're standing
in a different line alright there you go
I had a great [ __ ] argument today
talking about sports as always and as I
say that I looked at my my ring finger
on my left hand I sprained my finger
yesterday playing catch playing football
that's what I do at 43 I know what you
guys do you go down you probably have
your kids take them down to the eye and
ear doctor to make sure that they're
they're gonna be okay then you bring
them home you
your math you teach them right from
wrong I'm sure that that's what you're
doing you probably 10 years younger than
me into doing that me I'm out on a golf
course playing catch with the football
trying to learn how to throw with my
left hand I don't know why it's fun to
me
so the [ __ ] balls coming in and I
caught a couple one-handed and as I'm
going to stick my hand out to catch it
something in my brain goes don't do that
don't do that and then my ego said hey
[ __ ] you brain I'm running this [ __ ] all
right if I wanted any logical thought
out of you I would have asked a [ __ ]
question stand down sir so of course I
stick out my left hand dead I didn't Jam
it I gotta be honest with you if I had
to choose between jamming and spraining
I'm taking the sprain all day long Wow
look at that
it's purple all the way down to my so
anyways my finger Jesus Christ this
thing is disgusting it looks like you
know when a body has been floating in a
river and it said odd like shade of like
pasty in some areas yet dark purple and
others that's what my finger looks like
it looks like a kielbasa that's ready to
be taken off the grill and I did
everything I taped it up I put ice on it
I did the whole rice thing rest
inoculation [ __ ] and elevation whatever
it stands for I did the whole thing and
and it still still looks a little [ __ ]
up you know it's great about this is if
I were to get married tomorrow it
couldn't happen
would that nullify the wedding if you
couldn't put the ring on this finger huh
and that's stupid goddamn ceremony and
do you [ __ ] take this [ __ ] bride
to be your [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] wife
for the rest you got your [ __ ] life
unless you want to leave which boy
she'll take after your [ __ ] Wester me no
no now you got to take out the [ __ ]
gold shiny [ __ ] thing that they say
is where which probably [ __ ] is none
of us are miners so we don't know any
better if you could please take that
[ __ ] I don't
would fit that doesn't fit wait a minute
system Johnnie Cochran [ __ ] if the ring
don't fit you get to keep your [ __ ]
right now that was corny sorry [ __ ] you
it's only six minutes in I'll get to the
funny I'll get to the funny so yeah I
[ __ ] up my finger
yeah but trying to learn how to throw
left-handed you know and it's so awkward
it actually makes you laugh as you're
doing it I suggest tennis balls and you
throw it at a lazy boy do you guys
remember that uh
not Johnny Bench batter up what was that
other one we just got the little
backstop do you remember that and they
had the netting and you throw it and it
would bounce right back to you and you
could work on pitching and that type of
thing at least that's what they said but
was really basically uh for the kid with
no friends for the only child I'm
basically using my late lazy boy for
that wait a minute you know what that
reminds me of remember the baseball kid
they had this thing called the baseball
kid and the song was the baseball kid
the baseball kid baseballs what you
wanna do the baseball kid he'll pitch to
you right and it was this [ __ ]
cardboard cutout of what should have
been your best friend pitching the ball
to you but you didn't have one so then
they would just came up with this
cardboard cutout of the friend that you
don't have as cell phones the worst
invention ever when you're in a
relationship can they ever leave the
house without calling you two minutes
later how are we doing on string beans
do we have any string beans honey I know
you don't know I just could you just go
out in the kitchen and look we'll put it
on pause why are you yelling right isn't
that how it goes that half of the
conversation I'm but [ __ ] lievable
stop calling when you first got a cell
phone it was exciting exciting and new
pick it up
she's got nothing to say
but she'll still call you anyway so they
had this thing they have this thing
called the baseball kid and that was you
know and I remember came out when I was
in junior high and even then everybody
was joking that that's four so why
wouldn't you just have your friend pitch
and and the commercial was hilarious
because they'd have the baseball kid on
the pitcher's mound and then there'd be
the kid up to bat and then there'd be a
bunch of kids out in the outfield it's
[ __ ] stupid you got like eight kids
there that makes the baseball kid
obsolete but they couldn't show some
lonely kid sitting there with his arm
around a cardboard cutout that has a
face on one side but on the other side
it's just I imagine it's just cardboard
it's probably like you know when you
when you take a tour at Universal
Studios and you're like wow this is an
old western town and then they turn the
corner and you just see that's just the
the facade is that what you call it the
front of the building and everything
else is just a two-by-four behind it
yeah so that's basically what they had
back then it was basically for only
children so maybe with a fat kid you got
sick of people laughing it your uh
they're not really man tits when you're
still a kid but whatever we'll go with
man tits play well I have an idea what
if we had a cardboard cutout of someone
who could pitch to you is it gonna be
mean to me no tubby it's just gonna
throw you the ball that sounds wonderful
the baseball kid the bass book you know
what I'm sure on YouTube that they
actually have the commercial the
commercial so I'll try and find that if
I don't remember it please send it to
the mm podcast calm and we'll get it up
there for you or just search the the
baseball kid but you don't want to do
that you want to go to the mm podcast
com write the official podcast page of
the Monday morning podcast and we'll
have all the YouTube videos I actually
have one that somebody sent me on
of this guy with a speech impediment
this fat guy bitching how they [ __ ] up
his video game and he doesn't have a
lisp Lisp I don't know why just popped
the P there he doesn't have a lisp any
vocal coaches out there can tell me what
this is it's that one when you don't
have a list but you go successful
seriously stop it I'm curious I trying
to be successful that [ __ ] will you sort
of push the wind out on the side of your
tongue what's that one called the Lisp
is my horrible I do that's Jesus Christ
what's going on here that's a lisp I
know that but what is I cesspool it's a
[ __ ] cesspool what is that one
I know vocal fry is when you don't push
enough air through through your vocal
cords and I've joked here on the podcast
before every girl who is a [ __ ]
writing major in in college always talk
like that you know
Edith Wharton the magnitude of her work
can just not be cannot be magnetized did
I say that too many times I need to take
another writing course they'd speak like
that so anyways let's plow ahead here
with the podcast oh I have another
another a special amount announcement
this has been sort of like special
August hasn't it I have another special
announcement here introducing a lot of
people out there have been like going
hey Bill you know you do the Monday
morning podcast I like it I like that
you give me a free hour comedy every
week whilst whoring out whatever product
it is you have to sell you [ __ ] I
appreciate it
you know it would be better than that
what if you did another hour what if you
did another hour of free entertainment
and put it out on like a Thursday and
you know what I thought
I thought go [ __ ] yourself you greedy
prick I'm only doing one all right but
because enough of you requested that I
start doing to tell you what every once
in a while I'll do an extra one but you
got to pay for it all
Oh fuck-you you whiny pieces of [ __ ]
hear me out here my sales pitch before
you turn the channel alright Jesus
Christ you guys there any [ __ ]
loyalty I'm introducing uh
I was trying to think what is what what
I should call it and it's basically
gonna meet be me interviewing random
people in my life they're gonna be 99
cents they're called it's the Monday
morning podcasts select what inspired
this name I'll tell you you ever drink
some shitty American beer right it's not
shitty but you grew up with it and
remind you you you dad right you drink
like Budweiser or whatever whatever the
other ones like beer from Miller you
drink that [ __ ] and what did they do
with all these micro breweries coming up
for some reason all these blue-collar
beers had to have their fancy little
[ __ ] you know something select it's
basically why I'm calling it the Monday
morning podcast select cuz they would
always have like you know Budweiser
select or Miller select and it was
supposed to be like okay we really tried
to make it taste good on this one
right so that's what I'm calling it it's
the Monday morning podcast select and
this first one is gonna be out on
Thursday okay it's 99 cents and anybody
wants to whine about it go [ __ ] yourself
you already got a free hour of
entertainment here and you don't have to
pay this you don't have to pay for this
one no one's twisting your arm all right
you just wait for another free one every
Monday but if you want to a week I'm not
doing this every week people when I find
somebody that's interesting enough
because I think there's enough podcasts
out there
comedians interviewing other comedians
so I would like to try to do something a
little bit different so this Thursday if
you're a sports fan I interviewed
Ephraim Salaam he's a white guy who's
majored in accounting if anybody out
there knows a white guy named Ephraim
please send me the picture of him I want
to see it all right
with his Babe Ruth nose all right
plowing ahead here few people got that
all right I interviewed Ephraim Salaam
he played right tackle in the NFL I
should even say played because he's
officially he's not retired yet
officially he played with the the
Houston Texans last year he played for
14 seasons I believe in the NFL and I
basically asked this guy every goddamn
question I could think of that I ever
wanted to ask a football player you know
what's the dirtiest thing you ever did
to somebody what's the dirtiest thing
that was ever done to you what do people
say you ever get mad at the level of
[ __ ] quarterbacks get the real [ __ ]
alright you want that phony [ __ ] you
want to watch your your former heroes on
ESPN on that that fake football field
getting down to do a three-point stance
you want to watch that [ __ ] as they
explain the cover to what do you want to
hear about steroids you want to hear
about gold-digging [ __ ] you want to
hear the questions you want to hear the
answers to the questions you [ __ ]
have you don't skip you know it's
killing me you know the one I forgot to
ask him is what the [ __ ] what's the deal
with the prevent defense I forgot to ask
that one but I asked as many as I could
possibly ask and then in the end we
talked about that movie planet of the
apes it's 99 cents you know it's another
great way to contribute to the podcast
it's a way for me to give you something
extra and it's as always I always give
me the option right I give you the
[ __ ] option you don't have to it's
like the collection basket at church I
just pass it around if you put money in
I give you a little wink and I say a
prayer for you and if not I stare at you
and I wish that you go to health just
like a priest right isn't that what they
do speaking of which I saw a Planet of
the Apes this week and spoiler alert all
right I'm gonna talk about this movie
now because at this point if you haven't
seen it I think you still might
I'm not gonna tell you what happens but
I am gonna tell you I was I thought it
was awesome and I was disappointed all
at the same time and it's it's what I
said from day [ __ ] one I knew the
movie was gonna be great but I was upset
that it was pg-13 so you know something
I'm not even gonna talk about the movie
I can tell you this I am done with pg-13
pg-13
it's like decide who you want to make
this movie for okay is it for the kids
or is it for me make up your [ __ ]
mind stop being such a [ __ ] and just
sitting there on the fan for everybody
it isn't it's too [ __ ] scary for kids
and it in it and it's not quite violent
enough for me who's kidding who it's not
even close to violent enough for me I'm
done with it pg-13 is the movie version
of when a [ __ ] receiver goes over the
middle and he could reach out and catch
the ball but he's worried about the
[ __ ] cornerback so he pulls it in and
the [ __ ] ball skids down off the turf
that is that is the movie [ __ ] the
movie version of that play in NFL
football is is pg-13 [ __ ] pg-13 [ __ ] it
in its in its in its movie ass I am done
with it I'm done okay apes taking over
the world should either be the cutest
[ __ ] movie ever or I should be having
nightmares
don't [ __ ] drive them right down the
center of the road don't want to commit
went all Al Gore on me still an awesome
movie still recommend it
you're still gonna enjoy it but I wanted
someone to get their face ripped off
there I said it
okay and it's not like that is an
obscure thought we all saw that woman
she got a [ __ ] face ripped off by a
goddamn chimpanzee and there is this
lingering thought about chimpanzees that
they're nice that they
incapable of unbelievable levels of
[ __ ] violence because they've been
stereotyped in the studio system out
here in Hollywood from day [ __ ] one
they had Tarzan write king of the jungle
King in the jungle right this [ __ ]
white dude with no sunblock swinging
from [ __ ] vine to vine like that was
believable I thought that that was the
most unbelievable oh and the fact that
he could also have a white chick
girlfriend in the middle of [ __ ]
Africa how the [ __ ] did that happen you
know tralala she's just walking around I
don't remember the backstory let me just
finish this thought all right I thought
that that was the most unbelievable part
of it okay no bug spray no sunblock no
[ __ ] shoes and there's always another
vine to swing to you know I get
spider-man he shoots him out of his
wrist this [ __ ] is just conveniently
hanging all over the place anyways let
me plow ahead what the [ __ ] am I trying
to say here put them evidently the most
unbelievable thing about that was that
little [ __ ] monkey cheetah first of
all they didn't have it on a goddamn
leash they didn't have in a cage and
instead of jungle why is it hanging out
with you guys eventually it's just gonna
it's gonna take off but if you don't let
it take off it's gonna rip your face off
if you guys watch these things on the
Discovery Channel about these
chimpanzees going to eat other monkeys
and the way they did they they got a
whole ambush they flush them out and
they got other monkeys down the street
and the other [ __ ] trees and then
when they catch these monkeys they eat
him alive they could kill him they could
twist their little [ __ ] heads and
they don't they just stand on them as
they pull him apart as the little
monkeys got screaming it's [ __ ]
brains out
then after they do it they get all
excited who [ __ ] talk and [ __ ] you
know you see what the [ __ ] I did [ __ ]
you that was my move that's what they're
doing they're [ __ ] stop making them
[ __ ] cute ah
I swear to God if I ran a [ __ ] studio
and I'm a Planet of the Apes it would
have been [ __ ] nc-17 alright oh that
movie what that movie could have been
it's still [ __ ] great definitely go
see it but I'm telling you what that
movie could have [ __ ] been if they
weren't trying to [ __ ] market the
damn thing and get the you know did you
like the movie Cars well maybe you'll
like Apes taking over the world - Jesus
Christ you know it's just like sports
that's why there's so many goddamn
mascots out there it used to be for
drunks it used to be for people who
weren't happy and their [ __ ] marriages
sports fans
that's who it used to be for now they
got all these [ __ ] goddamn mascots
out there and they're trying to make it
a good time for the kids going to a live
sporting event is not a good time for
kids all right it's like a daytime strip
club
that's what you take them to - the horse
but the same [ __ ] drunks who were in
a titty bar the night before are sitting
next to your kids doing what it is that
they do and now they have to tone down
their [ __ ] because they got a big furry
[ __ ] mascot walking around I'll tell
you I've had it with these goddamn kids
all right they like the new [ __ ]
women you know women had to come into
every place that a guy was at and put up
curtains and [ __ ] ruin it right what
about us where we want to join your
men's club they were had to join the
country club they had to [ __ ] be able
to vote you know Jesus Christ I know
what I'm talking about it's [ __ ] hot
as hell in this goddamn rumble whatever
let's plow ahead here so [ __ ] pg-13 I'm
not doing that anymore it's either rated
R rated nc-17 or I want to go see Toy
Story all right
I don't want to see it I don't wanna see
any pg-13 that's like you [ __ ] shot a
three-pointer and you hit the back of
the rim and you you
want credit it almost went in oh sorry
I'm sorry I just like carnage um what
else what else did I want to talk about
here um doo-doo-doo-doo faint finger
went to that Oh I weighed myself this
morning people and I am down to 172
pounds I was up to 188 189 and it was
all booze cakes and pizza and all I've
done is I've cut out the booze in my
life and I bay it but able to gradually
over the last 10 months drop 17 [ __ ]
pounds of bloated facial weight and
mandatory
it's phenomenal all I just go on hikes
with my dog I do pull-ups and I do
push-ups and I've actually figured
something else out that I learned
through the p90x system p90x got
something called muscle confusion right
which is basically you know you have
your workout and after two weeks of
doing it your body starts to get used to
it see you stop getting results and can
actually I believe start to put on
weight just because your body is used to
it if you're eating like [ __ ] so then
they switch up the workout so your
muscles are like oh what the [ __ ]
alright so using that as a an
inspiration I have actually come up with
intestinal intestine confusion this is
what I do I eat perfect for three days
now right as my body gets used to to
just eating tremendously well I just
ought to know where I sucker punch it
with burgers fries and a shake and as it
rolls down the hill going what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] then the next day I start
with my oatmeal again and I go back
turkey slices and I eat well and it's
great all I gotta do is eat well for
like it's been working for me anyways
intestine confusion you heard it here
first
that's what I do because I think if you
eat well all the time your intestines
they start becoming like this
boiled rich-kid you know who got the car
when he was 16 you know you just start
taking [ __ ] for granted you don't give a
[ __ ] I think you're right your body does
that when you just eat well all the
goddamn time it just starts God yeah
that's just how it is you stop dropping
pounds I've actually found twice this
week I did it I almost ate a whole large
cheese pizza by myself and I was sitting
there on the couch in like the fetal
position like I can do four slices all
day long you can do it all day long run
out to the mailbox and come back and I
don't have a problem but when I go for
that fifth one forget it so I of course
I go for the fifth one I'm an American
right it's all about gluttony you know
we're not wearing skinny jeans over here
like those goddamn people over there in
Europe all right actually we are dude
how annoying are the skinny jeans yet
they're still hanging off somebody's ass
I swear to God
if I had a if I had martial arts
training to the point I was a black belt
in like four different styles and I had
a pistol not a stun gun I would run
around pulling up people's pants not
worrying and I would actually give him a
bit of a wedgie just not worrying about
you know and the only reason why I don't
do it is cuz I know I'm gonna get the
living [ __ ] kicked out of me but I just
want to run up behind these [ __ ] kids
oh and those God does and if you have on
the skinny ones you just [ __ ] just
yank them down and just boot them you
know what I shouldn't even say this cuz
this is gonna cause people to do this
[ __ ] like bullies they're gonna take it
from seriously um once you just love to
do it once just [ __ ] come up I mean
it's gotten to the [ __ ] point they're
so low some guys that they're almost
like did I already talk I feel already
talked about this [ __ ] it's like your
whole ass is hanging out of the back
you're in your underwear there's kids
around you know it's the worst two is
when they reach back to [ __ ] and pull
them up and you're like you're gonna
pull them up and they only only yank
them up like that's like I'm one of the
oldest stand-up bits ever but they only
yank them up like a [ __ ] eighth of an
inch it's like having somebody give you
a [ __ ]
scratch your back who can't find the
itch drives me crazy you know what
people I have to turn the fan on because
it's getting hot as hell in here hang on
one second all right but the magic of
the pause button I am back and the fan
still isn't really going hey I bought a
new toy there's a new [ __ ] toy in my
life I evidently I didn't realize that
the flip cameras are out now and there's
this new thing out there called the Q 3
HD zoom thing it's just basically it's
like a flip cam but it's a HD quality
I bought this the other day I went into
the stores looking at some drum [ __ ] and
I was talking about I wanted to start
making like drum covers just give you
guys something to laugh at and just see
how bad I am at drums but I don't want
to go through all the [ __ ] I'm
miking up drums and all that crap so
this guy showed me this thing and it's
[ __ ] insane HD quality it has and if
you buy that the 32 I don't what the
[ __ ] it's called 32 gig megahertz
[ __ ] [ __ ] face whatever I don't know
anything about it you can actually go up
seven hours seven [ __ ] hours that I
can record with in HD quality so I'm
like you know what I'm gonna get one of
these sons of [ __ ] and I'm gonna take
it out on the [ __ ] road with me I
could actually film this podcast right
now if I wanted to it's got that much
memory in an MV h HD quality but there's
two reasons why I'm not gonna do it
because this is [ __ ] radio and radio
is great lady radio is great because
right now you're listening to me while
do another [ __ ] alright the second I
make it video a it's boring to watch
someone sit here and talk B I don't want
you seeing what my [ __ ] apartment
looks like the shambles that it is and
yeah and then you also you can't [ __ ]
me can't clean your house to go to the
gym and do all go get through a flight
you're gonna sit there watching me
talking into a microphone what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you
why did I say that like you guys suggest
it's been people who suggest you should
start filming them and then what where
do I go from there
you should paint yourself it's somebody
come in and paint you while you do it
intestine confusion try it out eat
perfectly for like three [ __ ] days
right and then on the fourth day I mean
I'm not saying go nuts the whole goddamn
day but just one day just go up just
[ __ ] tear down a [ __ ] pizza place
right I'll just get a burger and fries
just eat until you can't [ __ ] eat
anymore
and then don't eat anything for the rest
of the goddamn day wake up the next day
you're back on the oatmeal back on the
[ __ ] you're back on the oatmeal you
go for a goddamn hike and you're all set
I'll tell you what I'm fascinated with I
want to do the I want to buy one of
those pegboard things you know lo see if
you guys seen those things and I don't
mean the thing you know what exactly do
you use a real I'm not talking like the
one you get at Staples I'm talking like
one when you're trying to become like a
ninja warrior so you can climb up the
side of [ __ ] some bullet-ridden
hideout and [ __ ] Jesus bill he just
ran out of references did you he's
trying to think of a Middle Eastern city
and Beirut back in the day anyways they
got these this thing called uh I think
it's just called the pegboard and it's
got these two sticks that hang out of it
they look like the same things that are
on the end of like nunchucks or like
those those stupid things that are the
percussive percussion instrument you
know anybody can play those can also
play the triangle and should also go
[ __ ] themselves but as far as the pay
pegboard goes it's basically you guys
probably already know what this [ __ ] is
some people might not know it so you got
those two things sticking out and you
can pull them out and you basically
climb your way up the pegboard sticking
it in a hole pulling it out this is very
phallic [ __ ] another hole pulling it
up you're not the one bang is this my
wife [ __ ] you I'm [ __ ] you and then
you go all the way up the top and then
you go to over to the side you come back
down again and then go back over the to
the side again and that's one cycle and
if you're a badass like that [ __ ]
maniac
p90x hehehe does a [ __ ] goddamn chin
up after he doesn't he's the first guy I
saw doing it I'm like I want to get one
of those and drill it to the inside wall
of my one-bedroom apartment you think I
get my deposit back I wonder
let's do YouTube videos of the week
before I get into advice here we got
some great ones this week I already
mentioned the fat guy flipping out with
the speech impediment that they screwed
up his goddamn game and part of me
thought it was fake but then I realized
like no he really talks that way he
really is upset but he's also hamming it
up because he thinks it's gonna people
are gonna be laughing with him rather
than at him that's what I feel it is all
right there's another one somebody sent
me last week it's called how to whistle
this is one of the most disgusting
creepy [ __ ] videos I've ever seen in
my life
this guy keeps just for people who have
a weak stomach this guy for some reason
keeps emphasizing how important it is to
have spittle on your lips and he takes
it off his lips with his fingers and he
plays with it and it's really [ __ ]
gross or hilarious depending on your
level of Tolerance here's when I was
watching I was watching some drum videos
and I came across this one and this dude
playing drums here is why I became a
comedian because back in the day when I
used to try and play drums and thought
for half a second that maybe I could
play in a band
I would see guys like this play and I
realized that it was just gonna be a
hobby
this guy is insane warning to people who
have sensitive ears this guy is playing
to a Bobby McFerrin song but what he's
playing is [ __ ] incredible the dude's
name is Jonathan Newman and I gathered
from his video that he goes to the
Berklee School of Music and he's got a
bunch of other videos up there him just
playing or playing with other beasts at
Berklee School of Music
drummers out there just someone who can
actually appreciate someone killing it
on an instrument this [ __ ] guy's
amazing and then the last one metal
filings in your freaking serial this one
is so creepy I think I'm gonna send it
out over my Twitter before we even post
it up because I just think everybody
ought to know this this guy does an
experiment with what looks like a cereal
that I've eaten a zillion times and you
know those cereals that claim that they
have a daily amount of iron in the
cereal well this guy was claiming that
there was actually the iron is actual
metal flakes in the cereal so to prove
it he dumped some of these flakes in a
bowl of water and then he takes a magnet
and these flakes start following the
magnet around the pool of water like a
goddamn junkie running after a bag of
meth it's really [ __ ] creepy and and
[ __ ] hilarious and just scary I was
up in the at the Montreal Comedy
Festival a few weeks ago and somebody
mentioned how somebody had gotten cancer
and this guy said Jesus Christ if one
more person gets cancer alright and who
knows I don't know if this is all tied
together I have no idea what just watch
this video it is it is really [ __ ] up
and I saw this and I'm like that's it
we're shopping at the health food store
but but no one no one house [ __ ] works
the the big guys they probably own the
health food store too but the bright
side is I think if you get enough of
this flaked cereal and you somehow are
able to get the iron shavings out of it
you know when the economy melts down and
you could make maybe a spearhead out of
it or some sort of a shield I actually
you know I was thinking the other day
have you ever seen those those videos on
YouTube where they talk about how they
built those FEMA camps all over this
country just in case another New Orleans
thing happens and when you look at and
it's for our own safety yet there's a
fence with barbed wire around the entire
facility
it's a [ __ ] prison I don't know who
it's for or what it's for and every time
I picture going into one of those I
always picture that Red Dawn you know
avenge me or whatever the name of that
movie was and I'm just like you just go
in there and you [ __ ] die right but I
actually have found a silver lining and
that silver lining is the now deceased
actor Jack Hsu he played one of the
detectives on Barney Miller and when he
was a kid he was Japanese American and
the Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor and
they rounded up all the
japanese-americans that they could find
and they they sent him to these I guess
they're considered concentration camps
there was sort of a debate about that
because there was no torture going on
but it's I guess the definition now
according to Wikipedia is that when a
select like a minority group of people
is all rounded up and they haven't done
a goddamn thing and they are stuck in a
camp and not allowed to leave that that
is a concentration camp and then of
course there's all different levels from
you just have to stay here and play
cards with each other until we kick your
country's ass in war all the way to the
absolute [ __ ] horror that happened in
Germany so anyways but Jack su was in
one of those the topes relocation Center
when he was a kid and you know what he
got out and 40 years later or whatever
thirty years later he was on Barney
Miller so there you go the economy
collapses and you end up in a Fema camp
do not give up hope you could one day
thirty years in the future become a star
of a of a sitcom and then die of cancer
of the oesophagus a little bit later
okay let's plow ahead here um Jani Lane
Dyke shout-out to JD Lane I didn't get
the [ __ ] I'm really bad at this [ __ ]
when people die you know as I mentioned
last week hair medal was my [ __ ] heavy
metal you know we didn't get too much
the speed metal I liked all that [ __ ] I
was of the perfect [ __ ] age it's not
dumb to me I don't give a [ __ ] go [ __ ]
yourselves and this guy I don't know
just another guy died way too [ __ ]
young so he's got kids so download some
of his music hopefully it will somehow
get to them
alright that's all depressing [ __ ] let's
let's [ __ ] it let's plow hit it alright
advice advice bill I am a 32 year old
born-again virgin and an eight by choice
[Laughter]
once again I haven't read these so I'm
discovering this [ __ ] right along with
you
I haven't been laid in years and don't
know why well it sounds like he got a
sense of humor so already serves
something positive you got a good sense
of humor he goes I'm not the ugliest guy
in the neighborhood but that ain't
enough the closest I came was a bj by a
thick chick last summer but even a guy
as desperate as me wouldn't wouldn't
[ __ ] her alright I have no problem
flirting with cute bartenders but just
can't seem to seal the deal maybe I'm
too picky but I have no interest in
screwing a broad I'm not attracted to
please help a fellow sunburnt [ __ ] like
yourself get back on the wagon loved the
podcast even more when Nia is on she
helps balance out your insanity please
help another horny Jesus Christ I can't
even read some of this [ __ ] people right
um alright alright dude I'm gonna
compare this you being a born-again
virgin as I'm gonna compare this to a
stand-up comedian who just shot an
hour-long special and now needs to write
a brand new hour of material okay
you're in a desperate situation you shot
the [ __ ] thing it went great
you're excited you celebrated that night
and then the next day the clocks tickin
your specials going to come out and
anywhere from 3 to 6 months and so you
basically it's probably to come out
probably like 4 or 5 months so you
basically have four or five
months to come up with a new hour of
material you know what the quickest way
to do that is sir not be picky when I
write a new auro material all rules of
hack are thrown in the garbage I don't
give a [ __ ] I'll do a Monica Lewinsky
joke anything to just be saying
something [ __ ] different to get me
talking about new [ __ ] so I can leave
the past behind and [ __ ] plow for and
even that hacky [ __ ] will lead to the
gold alright so let's get to you all of
a sudden you know I don't want to bang
this girl cuz she's thick you didn't say
fat she was thick sturdy could take a
pounding she's right there waiting for
it to go down you don't give it to her
you know you're [ __ ] you you're
trying to drink Johnny Walker blue right
now okay and you got you got two bucks
in your pocket alright it's time to go
with a little natty light in a [ __ ]
sense do you understand me sir and I'm
not saying that you go out there and go
bang some [ __ ] scabies ridden
prostitute I'm not saying that all right
go out there find yourself a girl looks
clean wear a [ __ ] condom and and and
you know as long as a consensual here
consensual sex you [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
of her
all right you'll get your little swagger
back you know when I'm putting together
my new hour and I [ __ ] hate myself on
stage and [ __ ] that would be a little
funny or isn't because I don't feel
strong and that's what you're doing you
don't feel strong right now all right
cuz you dicks been twisting in the wind
for god knows how long
so that's what I would do stop being so
goddamn so goddamn picky did my girl
just call me what did you say maybe that
was a neighbor yelling I have no idea so
that's what I would do sir just stop
being so goddamn picky but don't lower
your Standells to the point where you're
risking you know [ __ ] an STD or
impregnating some toothless [ __ ] you
understand me you know what you got to
do alright here we go
plowing it you like somebody who doesn't
have a job and then job himself in a
peon say
alright question uh question number two
hey Bill I'm a regular listener and
first-time writer I need your advice on
something 26 years old and I was
together with a lady for close to a year
and a half before dating her I was
pretty much a dog you know your typical
man-whore type no I know nothing about
that I'd basically bang anything with
this skirt on it well don't ever go to
Scotland thank you I'll be here all week
but this thing but this girl was
different I knew I knew her for a while
before we started dating and we were
amazing friends anyways I won't blab on
too much but dating her was great her
relationship with her dad was good so
you know she didn't have any issues and
[ __ ] but like in the middle of the
relationship I noticed her co-worker
would be extra flirty with her and stuff
Oh GJ's uh if this was a TV show they
would introduce that and then they would
go to commercial and you'd be like ah
but I want to see what's gonna happen
well here we go we're back from
commercial I always told her how it made
me uncomfortable and and [ __ ] that the
dude always tried to get with her and
stuff wait I thought this was a woman OH
I immediately assumed it was a woman I
wanted this to be uh oh this is a guy
oh that's extra oh Jesus ah Jesus Christ
these goddamn [ __ ] women what did she
do to you sir do I really got to read
this do I do I even need to read this
you're totally loving her you're
complete [ __ ] friends with her and
then she's flirting with this guy's
flirting with her too much and all of a
sudden now you're not going out with her
oh god these goddamn she's got damn
[ __ ] all right let's let's plow
ahead I just needed to regroup so
anyways I told her how it made me
uncomfortable and [ __ ] that the dude was
always trying to get with her and stuff
but she always assured me that she
didn't like the dude and she doesn't
respect guys like that who hit on girls
even though they are taken bull is she
is she
telling the guy to leave her alone Jesus
Christ a couple of months past and then
an incident happened she was at an
office party and according to her the
dude got super drunk and kissed her
anyways this happened on a weekend and
came clean about it the next day her
excuse was that he got drunk and kissed
her so it wasn't her fault
and that she didn't kiss him back so it
mean means there's nothing there of
course I didn't listen to that [ __ ]
and I dumped her within ten minutes of
being told of that time out a second I'm
gonna give you some applause there you
go exactly exactly I don't buy into that
crap that she didn't kiss him back cuz
in my head it's like she's saying oh he
had his dick in me but I didn't [ __ ] him
back so it's okay thank you sir I don't
even need to answer this you got your
head right where you need to be when
does a guy ever said oh honey don't
worry I didn't kiss her back and gotten
away scot-free if a guy said that he
would have got the [ __ ] kicked out of
her out of him by his girl I remember
the old uninformed episode where you and
Joe were talking about Michael Richard
to some PR guy and Joe said the problem
with the whole situations that Michael
Richards squirmed when he was
apologizing and didn't just own up to to
his fault that's why he wasn't forgiving
and that's the logic I use here that if
she just owned up to it that the dude
kissed her I could deal with it better
than her saying she didn't kiss him back
because back so I should be okay with it
okay home and he goes oh my god I'm
basing my relationship decision on what
Joe DeRosa says I think I've hit a new
low anyway not to make this email too
long but three months since we broke up
and I'm not really sure if it was the
right decision my gut said I did the
right thing but I'm questioning it dude
you're questioning it because you
because you love this girl on some level
and because you're lonely and you're
going through this [ __ ] but dude [ __ ]
that all right no offense but that [ __ ]
was disrespecting you from day one when
that bull [ __ ] was happening this guy's
drunk how did you
lips did 180 [ __ ] run across the room
like a Superman punch but with his lip
sticking out and she was talking to
somebody else and came over and kid he
was drunk what do what what led up to
the kiss what the [ __ ] were they talking
about they were talking about [ __ ] that
leads up to a kiss and your [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] of an ex-girlfriend sat
there in that [ __ ] moment letting
your [ __ ] get a little bit wet but not
really [ __ ] doing it
[ __ ] her dude I'm telling you right now
that was the tip of the goddamn iceberg
that's the lock the door test to the
10th [ __ ] power if you ever saw a
Bronx Tale that's it right there you
100% made the right [ __ ] decision
you're still a young guy there's a
better one coming your way who won't be
[ __ ] flirting with some dick at work
and accidentally getting kissed and you
think that that's the only thing that
happened that he accidentally just
kissed her and that's where the [ __ ] it
stopped
he didn't accidentally brush against one
of her titties [ __ ] that dude you did
the right thing
football seasons coming all that money
you would have spent on her go get
yourself a dish and get the [ __ ] NFL
package you deserve it alright go on
YouTube learn how to cook a perfect
steak on a hibachi and enjoy your
[ __ ] team for 16 games I'm telling
you let her fade the [ __ ] away and get
yourself a decent woman good for you sir
I applaud you I applaud you for the
[ __ ] decision you just made there
that that was like it was like and in
gymnastics when you just stick the
[ __ ] landing
TenPoint oh it's over give him the gold
medal you did the right thing
[ __ ] her all right that's just the
loneliness you'll find another gunner
good ones are hard to find so it's gonna
take longer than three months okay
but the last thing you want to do it's
over the trust is gone it's [ __ ] over
alright if you ever think of going back
to our real issen to this part of the
[ __ ] podcast it ends at 449 minutes
53 seconds so fast forward to that and
rewind and whatever [ __ ] two minutes
Jesus Christ you can kiss him back yeah
he didn't kick him in the balls either
or yell rape how the [ __ ] did he kiss
you
ah that's [ __ ] great you dumped her
good I hope she learns a lesson she
probably won't
dude she definitely has [ __ ] issues
and I'm telling you right now yeah why
do I keep over selling this all right
let's move on all right the next one
number three here okay oh the [ __ ]
uno dos tres and that's it that's that's
that's the length of I can speak three
languages if you if you want to count to
three other than that you're on your own
I would like to get your great sage
advice on a certain lady we'll call her
Mele that I can't get off my [ __ ]
mind and if Nia is around I wouldn't
mind some womanly advice too
you know what she's in the kitchen where
she [ __ ] belongs making me a goddamn
dinner and you know what I'm not even
lying that is that is where she is and
that is where she belongs I said the
kitchen where you belong
making me a dinner I said watch this
you're out in the kitchen where you
belong making me a dinner
I don't hear a feet are you just gonna
take that
what's the world hey somebody wants your
advice in here Hey
ah [ __ ] you there we go let's go here
here we go um well she's not around
evidently she's probably watching one of
those shows where people dance with no
shirts on dancing like a two-year
relationship they seem to always be
dancing some sort of relationship okay
and this in this dance like he loves her
but he can't be with her because the
King said don't do it and really that's
what you're doing there I thought you
guys would just spin it around on tables
I swear to god that [ __ ] goddamn
dance show America has talent I don't
know what it is but it's longer than the
HL [ __ ] playoffs I've come home she's
like she tapes like five of them and
then she'll watch them all at once and
it's it's like March Madness for
douchebags every time I come home the
[ __ ] show is on the only thing I will
give I'll give her credit for is she
fast-forward through that that chick
that looks like a [ __ ] toad who goes
where all the time if like what was what
the [ __ ] was Frank Giffords wife Kelly
Griffin whatever [ __ ] her name does she
ever [ __ ] up frog if she had facts sex
with a frog that's what it would look
like that goddamn flat-faced [ __ ]
weirdo oh well then that other guy with
his goddamn pointy nose he just got a
facelift oh Jesus
you still look like you were in your 50s
um anyways let's plow ahead here I'm 24
and she was my first long-term
girlfriend we were together on and off
for a year with two breaks both
initiated by me it was real it was a
real up-and-down thing and I don't just
mean in the bedroom she has a kid from a
previous dude dude open the passenger
side door and roll out I'm kidding it's
not nothing wrong she has a kid but you
know you're just adding a degree of
difficulty that doesn't need to happen
kind of like when the Rams played the
Patriots in the Super Bowl
there was no reason not to use Marshall
Faulk but for some reason they didn't
add at a degree of difficulty and what
happened the kick is up and it's good
all right plowing ahead here um so
anyway she had a kid from a previous
dude and I got along well with the kid
and I guess it's really matured me to
play stepdad for a year she had a lot of
mental issues medication she left a scar
on my upper arm when she bit me lots of
suicide threats my mom hates her my
friends hate her
dude are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] do I really
need to answer this
hey hey Nia how are you you look a
little angry come here they they need
they need your advice here I'm in here
because I needed you to come in here I
have to make it funny it wasn't funny
it's [ __ ] hilarious and all my
podcast listeners are laughing it's
comedy somebody's got to get hurt and
was your turn so quit your crying I'm
gonna read this because we only have one
microphone you're gonna shut your face
and when I'm done when I'm done I didn't
think you're gonna be on this one just
shut up cuz I don't have you miked
sweetie sweetheart love of my life
shut your face and let me read the rest
all right here we go all right let me
let me plow through this here because
the listener has already heard this
alright he's 24 years old he had a
long-term girlfriend they were on and
off for two years she has a kid from a
previous relationship he didn't mind
playing stepdad she has a lot of mental
issues she's on medication she's left a
scar on his upper arm where she bit him
lots of suicide threats you should see
the face she's making right now sir my
mom hates her my friends hate her for
some reason this guy needs advice when
she was normal this girl was [ __ ]
perfect
we had the same sense of humor got along
great it seemed like every time we were
together it would just get worse and
worse until I couldn't take it anymore I
told the [ __ ] off the first two times
she would call or message me message me
in a couple of months and then I'd end
up meeting her and we talked next thing
I know I'm back in the relationship it's
good and getting worse and then I tell
her to [ __ ] off again I've tried seeing
other girls in between nice girls normal
girls etc just can't get the same
connection as I had with Mellie what do
I do
does it just take more [ __ ] time
should I call her again but blah blah
blah dude I already know what's going on
this girl is a [ __ ] beast in the
bedroom she's an absolute beast in the
bedroom and he's running back to the
best [ __ ] he ever had because other
than that there's no [ __ ] come here
there's no reason ya crazy women are
insane in bed
yeah no she's probably really good in
bed because she's crazy but my friend
this girl needs help that you can't
provide she needs to be on medication
and therapy she's a mess and your
self-esteem is clearly pretty low
because you keep going back to this
basket case rub one out first and then
like once his his sexual desires from
her rub one out and the second you're
done cleaning up the [ __ ] mess you
created think about going back into it
yes yes it is yes I don't do this on
stage I don't do it on television this
is my outlet to be an absolute Pig I
love this [ __ ] podcast it keeps me
sane stop ruining my fun for what the
other mate will come back to bite me in
the ass is if I have a part on a sitcom
or I'm running for president and I can
live without either one of those all
right I'm happy I'm happy with who I got
so let me finish so rub one out
and afterwards think about being in a
relationship with her okay and there's
your [ __ ] answer that's it what you
have is a you're codependent look up
that word if you don't know what it
means but I don't I just meant that he
should look into it because it's like
it's it just means that you you need
this girl because you feel like you're
fulfilling some sort of role you know
like you if it makes you feel important
to sort of help her or be there for her
but it's it's all based on insecurity
and that's why you keep going back to
her you you deserve better than this
this is this is a ridiculous cycle that
you're putting yourself in it's
completely unnecessary so you need to
tell her to [ __ ] off and you need to
keep walking in the other direction and
don't let her seduce you with her
[ __ ] manic-depressive [ __ ]
[Laughter]
neiha he'll everybody god bless you
not now get out there and plate my food
woman don't don't I have to finish this
don't alright that was that wasn't you
know what you're capable of hitting
harder alright overrated underrated for
this week
underrated spreading jelly with a spoon
instead of a butter knife Jesus Christ I
never thought of doing that that
actually sounds uh like it could work
you can scoop the jelly with the spoon
and spread it with the back of it the
back of the spoon is as smooth is smooth
and round so it won't shred the bread
like a knife does and one less thing you
have to wash that's [ __ ] genius
overrated home ownership don't get me
wrong it's nice having a house where you
don't have to deal with neighbors coming
home drunk at 2:00 in the morning
blasting shitty Katy Perry music or have
to deal with some [ __ ] landlord any
time the heat stops working but the
thing with owning a house is that you
become the shitty landlord and have to
deal with all the problems yourself on
top of that you never really own the
place free and clear
let's just let's say some somehow you
manage to pay off the [ __ ] mortgage
you still have to deal with the taxes
and the monthly utility bills so it's
not like you can pay the [ __ ] off and
the next day retire and sit at home and
Stroke it to Three's Company dude
abso-fucking-lutely that's that's the
worst it's the worst that you know what
it is they won't let you sit down and
just go I worked for 30 years I want to
chill they won't let you do it that's
why it takes 30 years to pay off a
[ __ ] house because they want you to
get it at 30 and then by the time you
[ __ ] sixty your goddamn pancreas is
failing your health insurance [ __ ]
cancels you and then you got to sell the
house to pay for your medical bills and
then they move another 30 or 30 year-old
in there and they'd [ __ ] financially
bang him in the ass for the next 30
years so sir this is the secret the
secret is is you buy a house that you
can afford and I don't buy affording it
I don't mean the monthly pay
that's the slavery part of it all right
the running off the plantation part is
knocking down the principal so what you
do is you buy a house where you can
easily afford the monthly payment and
then you just kick the [ __ ] out of the
mortgage all right and then you still
have the property tax and all but that's
just how the game is played but at some
point it is you do want to live in a
house like me I still live in a
one-bedroom apartment and one of the
main reasons why I'm not filming this is
if you saw my one-bedroom apartment you
would not believe that I was playing a
[ __ ] funnybone forget about that I
can't even say the gig that I'm playing
it's it's it's so [ __ ] unreal to me
anyways here we go continuing with
underrated overrated I believe this is
under underrated New York what I really
mean is Manhattan but if you talk to any
of those [ __ ] whoa oh I guess this is
overrated
New York is overrated and what I really
mean is Manhattan but if you talk to any
of those fuckwads who live there they
call it New York equating Manhattan with
all of New York as if the rest of it the
state is lucky to be associated with the
prestige that those condescending pricks
think they have they'll let you know
that you're not really a New Yorker
because your phone number doesn't start
with 2 1 2 or that your city's not a
real city because it doesn't have the
culture that New York has to offer as if
having the good slice of pizza only
having a good slice of pizza in America
a few good steak joints in a theater
district makes it the pinnacle of
society in the center of the world per
square foot more [ __ ] than any city
hands-down it's the home of bankers
lawyers and advertising agencies Jesus I
can't argue with any of that and I live
there and I love that place but yeah
it's true New York City I would say it's
the easiest place to just go and have a
good time and to appreciate but if you
go to other places they're [ __ ]
amazing like I'm going to Nashville this
week to work as a knees in Nashville
gonna be there Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday or Friday Saturday yeah Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday
no Thursday Friday Saturday
Jesus Christ then I fly out and what was
I gonna say yeah when you're down there
there's this is what I learned this is
how I'm able I this is why I Love New
York in LA when I'm in New York I do New
York [ __ ] when I'm in LA I do LA [ __ ]
when I go to Tennessee I do tiny
Tennessee [ __ ]
I get barbecue slap my woman no sorry
I'll go to an SEC football game I'll
check out some music
I do Nashville [ __ ] I got a couple of
buddies out there that own a spread and
I'll go out and check out how they're
living it's a [ __ ] great time
enjoy the peacefulness of nature
speaking of which I went and I watched
my first meteor shower or is it
meteorite meteor makes it to the earth
meteorite burns up in the atmosphere
right we actually drove up into the
mountains and one of Nia's friends was
like let's go watch a meteor show so I
was like all right yeah let's [ __ ] do
it so I go up there and it was
absolutely amazing but there's too many
broads I liked all the women who were
there but Jesus Christ
you know the peace and the tranquility
that you get when you're out you know
that that uh what the [ __ ] is that guy's
name look I wrote about the pond Walden
whatever the [ __ ] his name is Henry
Thoreau you know what they talk about
they're basically one of the great
things about going out in nature it's
the peace of it
if you can just block out getting mauled
by a wild animal it's so quiet and it's
really great for you as a human being
and getting that peace and tranquility
when there's four or five broads in the
area it is impossible it is [ __ ]
impossible their their ability to
conversate non [ __ ] stop while
watching a meteorite shower whatever the
[ __ ] you call they would just be like oh
my god you just think Lee last week why
it's though it felt like this oh my god
she's such a [ __ ] and as they're
talking one would
across the sky and they would just react
to it and then go right back to it oh my
god it has it so anyways I like season 2
better than season 3 I just don't know
why they took her carrot woo that's all
they were doing and it drove me [ __ ]
insane drove me [ __ ] insane Hey look
who's back because Nia when you're in
nature it's nice when it's quiet every
once in a while you guys were talking
about the box set of Six Feet Under
while watching this [ __ ] it was you know
just because one person doesn't mean
everyone else has to be quiet we were
enjoying ourselves we were laughing
together we're having a good time I know
I know I know I know I know I know but I
I felt like I was in an airport terminal
surrounded by five strangers on their
cell phone well I mean you guys really
weren't talking about [ __ ] you guys were
talking about a play okay I don't want
to argue with you two weeks in a row in
the podcast you made me dinner okay you
earned your keep today I appreciate that
I'm just [ __ ] with you
you can swear to God what all right
gorgeous I'll see you in a minute all
right I don't know if this is overrated
or underrated I have to figure this out
as I read it early retirement sure if
you love your job retiring isn't a big
deal and probably means you're left with
finding things to do but the fact that
99.9% of the people hate their jobs and
are working for that dangling retirement
carrot carrot which keeps getting pushed
out farther and farther it used to be 65
but now the way the country is going
with and with 401ks getting raped you're
more likely to retire in your 70s if not
later
I'll see you're saying the the the dream
of retiring early yeah but you know
something you can do it if you're
willing to live with less you
retire early you don't have to have one
of those MTV Cribs [ __ ] lifes you
don't have to have it I mean you could
end up like me 43 no one-bedroom
apartment but you know there's something
to be said about not being buried and
[ __ ] dead I still have to work taxman
still bugs me but uh you know I can go
see a movie whenever I want to I don't
what the [ __ ] I'm saying you know I saw
Sean Penn bought this giant plot of land
and just put a [ __ ]
trailer on it and I was like that's
genius
lives in the middle of nowhere what do
you really need
ah [ __ ] that I would go crazy in that
maybe get a double-wide but there there
there are options you don't oh did we
talk about this last week have you seen
those tiny houses that they're that are
allegedly all the rage their tiny houses
they're like the size they're like the
size of a [ __ ] studio apart apartment
maybe they look like giant doll houses
for rich kids to go play in there like
tree forts and they're like 15 grand and
you basically yeah it's like it's like
paying off a what's a good car a Honda
Civic with no options not even that I
mean I what can you get a car for 15
grand it might be one of those smart
cars there's no [ __ ] way there's no
way if I buy a house if it went to buy a
house I want to buy something where it's
cozy but it's big enough where I can get
the [ __ ] away from anybody else who's
living in it and I don't mean that in a
bad way I just think it's really
important to be by yourself for a
certain amount of time every single day
you know at some point you have to go
[ __ ] off go for a walk you know do
something
I don't know I don't know what happened
to this podcast everybody but listen
remember if you want to listen to
another if you want to listen to a great
hour i interviewee from salaam it's the
Monday morning podcast select it will be
up and available for download on the mmm
podcast calm oh the the mmm podcast.com
fanpage the official fanpage of the
Monday morning podcast will have a link
you pay 99 cents and I got to tell you
II from was a ridiculously awesome guest
and I even said to him at one point I go
why don't you do radio or TV and he says
because I say [ __ ] and [ __ ] too much
which God knows I can relate to that so
we headed off everything was great and
uh and listening if you'd like and if
not don't all right so that's it so
that's your option you can listen if you
want you don't have to so I don't hear
any of you [ __ ] crying Emile it wasn't
that free life isn't free people of this
generation I know you get your music and
your movies and everything else for
[ __ ] free this isn't free this cost
99 cents go [ __ ] yourselves that's the
podcast for this week don't take any
[ __ ] and it's almost football season and
I'm excited about that talk to you next
week
[Music]